Earlier this month, when the bomb went off in the St. Petersburg subway station, killing 14 people, Anna Nemtsova was in a cafe in Moscow. She's a Russian reporter, currently a correspondent for The Daily Beast. The bombing was blamed on a suicide bomber, a 22-year-old from Kyrgyzstan. But in this cafe, Anna says, as soon as people saw the news on their phones--
本月初，当圣彼得堡地铁站发生爆炸，造成14人死亡时，安娜·涅姆佐娃正坐在莫斯科的一家咖啡馆里。她是一名俄罗斯记者，目前为《野兽日报》担任通讯员。这次爆炸被归咎于一名来自吉尔吉斯斯坦的22岁自杀式袭击者。但安娜说，在那家咖啡馆里，人们一在手机上看到新闻——
Minutes after the attack took place in St. Petersburg people were still in shock and the first thing that came up to their mind was that the government was blowing up St. Petersburg metro. Nobody else but the government. That was a shocking conspiracy theory that they heard--
袭击发生在圣彼得堡后的几分钟内，人们仍然处于震惊之中，他们脑海中浮现出的第一件事就是政府炸毁了圣彼得堡的地铁。除了政府还能有谁。这是他们听到的一个令人震惊的阴谋论——
Right. So they have no evidence that that's true.
没错。所以他们没有任何证据证明这是真的。
Zero. Absolutely zero evidence. Yeah. And they say they're doing this to distract our attention from their opposition rallies.
零。绝对零证据。是的。他们说政府这样做是为了分散我们对反对派集会的注意力。
She's talking about the opposition rallies that were just a week before the bombing-- the largest in years-- in dozens of cities across the country. So people thought--
她说的是爆炸发生前一周举行的反对派集会——这是多年来规模最大的一次——遍及全国几十个城市。所以人们认为——
Now they're trying to distract our attention from the protests.
现在他们正试图分散我们对示威活动的注意力。
The fact is, though, the 22-year-old suspect in the bombing really might have done it. Investigators have released a still of him entering the subway, taken from video surveillance footage. They said they have DNA evidence, too. But no evidence so far linking him to ISIS or any other radical group. And no group has claimed responsibility for the bombing.
然而事实是，那名22岁的爆炸嫌疑人确实可能就是凶手。调查人员发布了一张他进入地铁时的静止图像，取自监控录像。他们还表示掌握了DNA证据。但到目前为止，还没有证据将他与ISIS或任何其他激进组织联系起来。也没有任何组织宣称对爆炸负责。
But even if the government did produce definitive evidence, Anna says, people would take it with a huge grain of salt, given the general level of misinformation disseminated by the government all the time. Russian state TV right now says, for example, Syrian President Assad has nothing to do with the chemical attacks in his country. And in the aftermath of the St. Petersburg bombing, all sorts of rumors and conspiracy theories started circulating in Russia. On state TV, Anna saw a pro-Kremlin commentator named Alexander Prokhanov peddling a theory that was the exact opposite of what people in the cafe thought. That theory?
但安娜说，即使政府拿出了确凿的证据，人们也会持极大的怀疑态度，因为政府一直都在散布各种错误信息。例如，俄罗斯国家电视台现在宣称，叙利亚总统阿萨德与该国发生的化学武器袭击无关。在圣彼得堡爆炸案发生后，各种谣言和阴谋论开始在俄罗斯流传。安娜在国家电视台上看到一位亲克里姆林宫的评论员亚历山大·普罗汉诺夫兜售一种理论，这与咖啡馆里人们的想法截然相反。那个理论是什么？
This attack was plotted and performed by the same people who staged the anti-Putin protests in Moscow. So in other words, he blamed the Russian opposition. He accuses them of blowing up a train with people in St. Petersburg.
这次袭击是由策划莫斯科反普京抗议活动的同一伙人策划并实施的。换句话说，他指责了俄罗斯反对派。他指控他们炸毁了圣彼得堡的一列载人火车。
The day of the bombing, 500 journalists happened to be in St. Petersburg for a conference with Vladimir Putin. And lots of people said the timing was intentional, that the bomber wanted so many journalists there to cover the event and help the government foment fear about terrorism and distract from the protesters. Or possibly the complete opposite. The bomber wanted all those reporters to embarrass the government with lots of coverage of the atrocity.
爆炸发生当天，正好有500名记者在圣彼得堡参加与弗拉基米尔·普京的会议。许多人说时机是故意的，炸弹袭击者希望有这么多记者在场来报道这一事件，并帮助政府煽动对恐怖主义的恐惧，从而分散对示威者的注意力。或者，完全相反。袭击者希望所有这些记者通过对暴行的大量报道，让政府感到难堪。
A Moscow cab driver told Anna the fringiest conspiracy theory she heard-- that the cops did it.
一位莫斯科出租车司机告诉安娜她听到的最离奇的阴谋论——是警察干的。
So the taxi driver was saying, uh-huh, the police blew up the train themselves to receive more money to fight terrorism in St. Petersburg and to receive epaulettes to be decorated.
所以出租车司机说，嗯，是警察自己炸毁了火车，为了获得更多的反恐资金，为了获得肩章，为了获得嘉奖。
I have to say, I find that theory even more depressing than the thought that the government would set the--
我不得不说，我觉得这个理论比“政府会制造……”的想法更令人沮丧。
It is extremely depressing. It is extremely depressing, and it is madness. It can drive you crazy. When you hear so many completely opposite theories and people jumping to conclusions without having any information, any evidence, the truth is dissolving. It's becoming more and more blurry.
这极其令人沮丧。这极其令人沮丧，而且是疯狂的。这会让人发疯。当你听到这么多截然相反的理论，人们在没有任何信息、没有任何证据的情况下就草率下结论时，真相正在消散。它变得越来越模糊。
And it's not just Russians speculating about what happens in Russia. We speculate, too. Especially about Russia's leader, Vladimir Putin, who's either, you know, a man battling suicide bombers, or possibly a man who gave orders to blow up 14 innocent people to take everybody's mind off some protest marches.
而且不仅仅是俄罗斯人在推测俄罗斯发生的事情。我们也推测。特别是关于俄罗斯领导人弗拉基米尔·普京，他要么是一个与自杀式炸弹袭击者作战的人，要么是一个可能下令炸死14名无辜者，好让大家不去想抗议游行的人。
There's a journalist named Keith Gessen, who was born in Russia and has written about it for years, who recently wrote, quote, "at no time in history have more people with less knowledge and greater outrage" speculated about Russia's president. Is he a political genius? Is he a man just trying to get rich? Is he a guy who wanted to be part of NATO and an ally to the West, who we spurned and now he's acting out of revenge?
有一位名叫基思·格森的记者，他出生在俄罗斯，多年来一直在撰写有关俄罗斯的文章，他最近写道：“历史上从未有这么多人，在知之甚少的情况下，带着极大的愤慨”，推测着俄罗斯总统。他是政治天才吗？他只是个想发财的人吗？他是一个曾经想加入北约并成为西方盟友，却被我们拒绝，现在出于报复而行事的人吗？
Today on our program, we try to understand a little bit more about who Putin is and how he operates. He's been in the news for months. And I'll be frank. There are still some basic things about him and about Russia I went into this show feeling like I really did not understand, including-- I don't know if you've heard this one-- did he come to power in 1999 by first killing off a few hundred innocent Russians? And do people think about that and talk about that in Russia today? That's going to be the first thing we take up.
今天在我们的节目中，我们试图更多地了解普京是谁以及他如何运作。几个月来他一直在新闻头条上。坦率地说，关于他本人和俄罗斯，还有一些基本的东西，我在做这个节目时感觉自己真的没有弄明白，包括——我不知道你是否听过这个——他是通过在1999年首先杀害几百名无辜的俄罗斯人而上台的吗？在今天的俄罗斯，人们会思考并谈论这个问题吗？这将是我们讨论的第一件事。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us, comrades.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台的《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。同志们，请继续收听。
Act One, Going in with a Bang.
第一幕，轰然登场。
So have you heard this story? I just heard this for the first time recently. Long before this month's St. Petersburg bombing, there was another bombing that people speculated about. And in that one, there actually was some evidence that raised real questions. It happened right when Vladimir Putin was coming to power. This was back in 1999. Boris Yeltsin was president, running Russia. Putin was the prime minister. Not well-known, not well-liked, polling at 2% as a possible presidential candidate.
所以，你听过这个故事吗？我最近才第一次听说。在这个月圣彼得堡爆炸案发生很久之前，还有另一起引起人们推测的爆炸案。而在那次事件中，确实有一些证据提出了真正的疑问。它发生在弗拉基米尔·普京即将上台时。那是1999年。鲍里斯·叶利钦是总统，掌管俄罗斯。普京是总理。他并不出名，也不受人欢迎，作为潜在的总统候选人，民调支持率仅为2%。
And then-- Putin had only been prime minister for a month-- there was a series of bombings of apartment buildings in Moscow and elsewhere. 300 people died. Putin blamed it on Chechen rebels, invaded Chechnya, started the Second Chechen War, which he won. It was a popular war. Catapulted him into the presidency. When he took office, he had 53% of the vote. And even back then, when he took office in 2000, there was a question. Did he bomb those buildings himself to create the pretext for the war and his own rise to power? If he did, of course it calls the legitimacy of his presidency into question in a big way, murdering his own constituents-- exactly the kinds of Russians that he claims to be serving and protecting as president.
然后——普京担任总理才一个月——莫斯科和其他地方发生了一系列公寓大楼爆炸案。300人死亡。普京将其归咎于车臣叛军，入侵了车臣，发动了第二次车臣战争，并取得了胜利。那是一场受欢迎的战争。这使他一跃成为总统。当他就职时，他获得了53%的选票。即便在那时，当他在2000年就职时，就有一个问题。是他为了制造发动战争和自己上台的借口而亲自炸毁了那些大楼吗？如果他真的这么做了，当然这会严重质疑他总统职位的合法性，谋杀他自己的选民——正是那些他声称作为总统要服务和保护的俄罗斯人。
One of our producers, Robyn Semien, talked to reporters who covered this and reviewed the evidence with them.
我们的制片人之一罗宾·塞米恩，与报道过此事的记者进行了交谈，并与他们一起审查了证据。
Before we get to the more mysterious aspects of the bombings, a quick summary of what happened. The bombings came in fast succession. Four bombs in two weeks in random locations in Moscow and two other cities. Early September was the first one. A bomb in a truck went off right outside an apartment building, collapsing it. Over 60 people died. Days later, thousands of miles away, another bomb goes off on the ground floor of a nine story apartment building. Nine stories flattened, killing over 90 people. Within days, there was another one, and then a fourth. Buildings destroyed in the night while people were inside, sleeping.
在我们进入爆炸案更神秘的方面之前，先快速总结一下发生了什么。爆炸接连发生。两周内在莫斯科和其他两个城市发生了四起爆炸。9月初是第一次。一辆卡车里的炸弹在公寓大楼外爆炸，导致大楼倒塌。60多人死亡。几天后，在数千英里外，另一枚炸弹在一栋九层公寓大楼的底层爆炸。九层楼被夷为平地，造成90多人死亡。几天之内，又发生了一起，然后是第四起。建筑物在深夜被毁，当时人们正在里面睡觉。
David Satter was in and out of the country at the time. He's been reporting on Russia since the '70s.
大卫·萨特当时进出该国。他从70年代就开始报道俄罗斯。
It was an atmosphere of panic. The whole country was terrified. People began to fear that any apartment building could be blown up in the middle of the night and any family could be buried under the rubble.
当时充满了恐慌的气氛。整个国家都处于极度恐惧中。人们开始担心任何公寓大楼都可能在深夜被炸毁，任何家庭都可能被埋在废墟之下。
There are 30,000 apartment blocks in Moscow, and night patrols were organized in all of them to prevent terrorists from putting bombs in the basements.
莫斯科有3万个公寓区，所有这些地方都组织了夜间巡逻，以防止恐怖分子在地下室安放炸弹。
The government immediately blamed the bombings on Chechen guerrillas. Scott Anderson is another reporter who's written about the attacks.
政府立即将爆炸归咎于车臣游击队。斯科特·安德森是另一位写过这些袭击事件的记者。
Chechens tend to be more darkly complected than your typical ethnic Russians, so anyone who was darkly complected on the streets of Moscow was subject to arrest or being beaten up. And so a lot of people from the Caucasus, they would just stay inside. They were afraid to go out in the streets.
车臣人的肤色往往比典型的俄罗斯族人更黑，所以任何走在莫斯科街头上肤色较深的人，都容易受到逮捕或殴打。因此，许多来自高加索地区的人干脆待在家里。他们不敢走到街上。
But this story that Chechens were behind the bombings was kind of fishy. For starters, it was three years after Chechnya and Russia had finished a war-- the First Chechen War. Chechnya basically won. They signed a peace treaty. Again, Scott.
但车臣人是爆炸幕后黑手的说法有点可疑。首先，那是车臣和俄罗斯结束一场战争——第一次车臣战争——三年后。车臣基本上赢了。他们签署了和平条约。再次提到斯科特。
What motive did the Chechens have to start this bombing campaign against Russia when they pretty much had everything they wanted? There was no reason to fight the Russians at this point.
当车臣人几乎得到了他们想要的一切时，他们有什么动机对俄罗斯发动这场爆炸运动呢？在这一点上，没有理由与俄罗斯人作战。
Right. They'd won the war.
对。他们赢了战争。
That's right. They had won the war.
没错。他们赢了战争。
So why commit acts of terror that were big enough to start another war? And just logistically, it would have been hard to pull off.
那么，为什么要进行足以引发另一场战争的恐怖活动呢？仅仅从后勤角度看，也很难做到。
Even in 1999, Russia was a very heavily policed state. And so certainly by after the second or third bombing, there were police checkpoints certainly all over Moscow-- all over major Russian cities. So the idea of these bombers moving around-- and these are kind of crude explosives. They're very heavy. 50-Kilo sacks of explosives you need to haul around, so you need a car. So you're going through checkpoints. And with the whole hysteria against Chechens, certainly anybody who was, again, darkly complected, going through a checkpoint was going to be thoroughly searched.
即使在1999年，俄罗斯也是一个警察森严的国家。所以肯定在第二或第三次爆炸之后，莫斯科各地、俄罗斯各大城市到处都是警察检查站。所以这些炸弹袭击者四处移动的想法——这些是粗糙的炸药。它们非常重。你需要拖着50公斤重的炸药袋，所以你需要一辆车。所以你要经过检查站。再加上针对车臣人的歇斯底里，当然任何肤色较深的人经过检查站时都会被彻底搜查。
Even some people in the government questioned the official account. David Satter was in Moscow right after the bombings. And a friend who had good connections told David there were people in the security services who suspected the FSB-- that's the modern version of the KGB, basically-- might be behind the bombings. So David asked to meet some of those guys in person. And they agreed. But this was such a dangerous idea, they wanted to make sure they weren't caught. So they had this very private conversation in a very public place-- in the center of Moscow.
甚至政府内部的一些人也质疑官方的说法。爆炸发生后，大卫·萨特在莫斯科。一位关系很好的朋友告诉大卫，安全部门有人怀疑FSB——那是克格勃的现代版本，基本上——可能是爆炸案的幕后黑手。所以大卫要求亲自会见那些人。他们同意了。但这想法太危险了，他们必须确保不被抓到。所以他们在莫斯科市中心的一个非常公开的地方进行了这次非常私密的谈话。
I don't want to give away too many details--
我不想透露太多细节——
It's OK.
没关系。
--but it was in a store of some sort, in a building not far from the Bolshoi Theatre. And people coming and going, but we didn't give any indication what we were talking about. Just a couple of men standing there, talking about something.
——但那是在大剧院附近的一家商店里。人们来来往往，但我们没有表现出我们在谈论什么。只是两个男人站在那里，谈论着什么。
The agents didn't have proof, but some things just didn't add up.
这些特工没有证据，但有些事情就是说不通。
For example, the simple fact that the buildings were blown up with hexogen, which is a very, very powerful explosive that's used to top off artillery shells and is available only in one factory in Russia, which is tightly guarded by the FSB.
例如，简单的事实是，这些建筑物是被黑索金炸毁的，这是一种非常、非常强大的炸药，用于填充炮弹，并且在俄罗斯只有一家工厂可以生产，而该工厂由FSB严密看守。
It's also at military bases. But how would terrorists get hexogen at all, the agent said, let alone drive big quantities of it around Russia unchecked?
它也存在于军事基地。但特工说，恐怖分子怎么可能搞到黑索金，更不用说将大量炸药在俄罗斯境内四处运输而不被发现？
When you heard this stuff, were you thinking these arguments were convincing, or were you also thinking... well?
当你听到这些东西时，你认为这些论点有说服力吗，还是你也认为……嗯？
I wasn't completely convinced that this was a government provocation. But what convinced me was the bomb that did not go off, the fifth bomb.
我并不完全相信这是一场政府挑衅。但让我信服的是那枚没有爆炸的第五枚炸弹。
The fifth bomb in yet another city-- Ryazan. And this is where the story about the Chechens seems to really fall apart, and where the story gets truly strange.
在另一个城市梁赞的第五枚炸弹。这就是车臣人故事似乎真正站不住脚的地方，也是故事变得真正诡异的地方。
September 22, 1999, 2 and 1/2 weeks after the first apartment bomb. A couple of residents in a building in Ryazan noticed something weird. One guy, a bus driver who lived in the building, saw a car, a white sedan, parked outside the building. Maura Reynolds was a foreign correspondent for the LA Times back then, living in Moscow. She talked to the guy, who told her the license plates on the car didn't look right. They had a local city code on them for Ryazan-- the number 62. But, he told Maura, when he looked closer, he saw that the number--
1999年9月22日，也就是第一起公寓爆炸案发生两周半后。梁赞一栋大楼的几位居民发现了一些奇怪的事情。一个住在楼里的公交车司机看到一辆白色轿车停在楼外。莫拉·雷诺兹当时是《洛杉矶时报》的外国通讯员，住在莫斯科。她和那个人谈过，那个人告诉她车上的牌照看起来不对劲。上面有梁赞当地的城市代码——数字62。但是，他告诉莫拉，当他仔细看时，他看到那个数字——
It had been written on. It had been drawn on by hand. It didn't look like it was stamped into the metal license plate.
它是被写上去的。它是手工画上去的。它看起来不像是在金属车牌上冲压出来的。
Like with a Sharpie or something?
就像用记号笔之类的东西？
Yeah. Like a magic marker on a piece of paper taped over the license plate.
是的。就像用记号笔写在一张贴在车牌上的纸上。
Oh.
哦。
And that was immediately something that he thought, huh?
这立刻让他产生了一种想法，呵？
So he calls the police. In the meantime, two men get out of the car.
于是他报了警。与此同时，两个男人从车里出来。
And start carrying heavy sacks of something into the building's basement. The people jump back in the car. They take off.
开始搬运装有东西的沉重袋子到大楼的地下室。那些人跳回车里。他们跑了。
That's Scott Anderson again. The local police show up.
又是斯科特·安德森。当地警察出现了。
They went down into the basement and came running back up, saying, it's a bomb. It's a bomb.
他们下到地下室又跑回来，说，是炸弹。是炸弹。
Ryazan is essentially sealed off within hours. Thousands and thousands of soldiers and police cordon off the city, and they begin this massive dragnet for these two men and a woman who was the car, also.
梁赞在几个小时内基本被封锁了。成千上万的士兵和警察封锁了城市，他们开始对这两个男人和车里的一个女人进行大规模搜捕。
Local FSB start combing through evidence. A detonator was found in the basement.
当地FSB开始梳理证据。在地下室发现了一个雷管。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Here's a TV news clip from then, from a documentary about the bombings called Disbelief. The reporter says, "the sacks were discovered by police."
这是一段当时电视新闻的剪辑，来自一部关于爆炸案的纪录片《不信任》。记者说，“这些袋子是警察发现的。”
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
The sacks were taken to a lab that concluded the contents were hexogen, the same explosive used to blow up the other buildings-- the stuff that supposedly only the FSB and military had access to.
这些袋子被送到实验室，结论是其中的内容物是黑索金，也就是用来炸毁其他建筑物的同一种炸药——那种据称只有FSB和军方才能接触到的东西。
One day after the bomb scare, prime minister Vladimir Putin, who, remember, has only been in the job for a month, launches the Second War against Chechnya over the bombings. He says, quote, "the question is closed once and for all. We will pursue the terrorists everywhere. If they are in an airport, then in an airport. And forgive me, if we catch them in the crapper, then we'll rub them out in the crapper," unquote.
炸弹恐慌发生一天后，总理弗拉基米尔·普京，记住，他才上任一个月，就因这些爆炸案发动了第二次车臣战争。他说，引述：“这个问题彻底关闭了。我们将到处追捕恐怖分子。如果他们在机场，那就在机场。请原谅，如果我们在茅房抓到他们，那我们就把他们就在茅房里消灭掉，”引述结束。
Meanwhile, back in Ryazan, local police find the mysterious white sedan and the two suspects. They were not Chechen. They were Russian. Russian FSB agents with FSB IDs.
与此同时，在梁赞，当地警察发现了那辆神秘的白色轿车和两名嫌疑人。他们不是车臣人。他们是俄罗斯人。拥有FSB证件的俄罗斯FSB特工。
The head of the FSB, Nikolai Patrushev, goes on TV and is like, there's a totally reasonable explanation for FSB agents to be caught doing this. The whole thing was a drill. This audio of that announcement is from a documentary about the bombings, called Blowing Up Russia.
FSB负责人尼古拉·帕特鲁舍夫出现在电视上，说，FSB特工被抓到做这种事有一个完全合理的解释。整件事是一次演习。这段宣布的录音来自一部关于爆炸案的纪录片，名为《炸毁俄罗斯》。
First of all, there wasn't an explosion, and an explosion wasn't prevented. But it wasn't good work. It was an exercise.
首先，没有发生爆炸，也没有阻止爆炸。但这不是工作出色。这是一个演习。
He goes in front of the cameras. He makes this little statement.
他站在摄像机前。他发表了这个简短声明。
Again, Scott Anderson.
再次提到斯科特·安德森。
He doesn't take questions. He walks away. It's just like, oh, yeah, that was just a military exercise.
他不接受提问。他走开了。就像，哦，是的，那只是一次军事演习。
As for the hexogen, there was no hexogen, he says. There were no explosives. The white powder in the bags, he explains, was sugar.
至于黑索金，他说没有黑索金。没有炸药。袋子里的白色粉末，他解释说，是糖。
Maura Reynolds talked to people who lived in the apartment building in Ryazan back then. She says people were angry, and they thought their own government had tried to kill them. Though, of course, since this was Russia--
莫拉·雷诺兹当时和住在梁赞那栋公寓大楼里的人交谈过。她说人们很愤怒，他们认为自己的政府试图杀害他们。当然，因为这是俄罗斯——
They wouldn't say it quite that way. What they would say over and over again was in the form of a question. Whose interests were served by this? Who had something to gain? It doesn't make sense, but who had something to gain?
他们不会以那种方式直说。他们一遍又一遍说的是一个问题。谁的利益得到了满足？谁从中获益？这说不通，但谁获益了？
Would you ask them, who do you think?
你会问他们，你认为是谁吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And what would people say?
人们会说什么？
Who else? The government. But let me say that some weren't willing to go to say that out loud. They would say, who had something to gain? And then there would be a pause and they would raise their eyebrows. And I would say, who do you think? And they'd say, who do you think?
还能有谁？政府。但让我说，有些人不愿意大声说出来。他们会说，谁获益了？然后会有一阵停顿，他们会挑起眉毛。我会说，你认为是哪一方？他们会说，你认为是哪一方？
At the time, there was still something of a free press. People could speak out, and did.
当时，新闻自由尚存。人们可以发言，也确实发了言。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
This is tape from a TV special on an independent channel, the NTV network, which has since been taken over by the state. The special is like a talk show, with a host, some FSB higher-ups, and people from the building, who are pretty mad. Again, this comes from the documentary Disbelief.
这是来自一家独立频道NTV网络电视特别节目的磁带，该频道后来被国家接管了。特别节目就像一个脱口秀，主持人、一些FSB高层和楼里的居民，他们非常愤怒。同样，这来自纪录片《不信任》。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
He's saying, the people of Ryazan and many other towns just do not believe all these stories. I'm sitting here and just cannot believe the story the FSB is telling. I myself am a military officer. I was a senior officer for 28 years. I was in charge of countless exercises. What these generals are claiming about this so-called exercise, I just can't believe my ears.
他说，梁赞和许多其他城镇的人民就是不相信这些故事。我坐在那儿，简直不敢相信FSB编出的故事。我本人是一名军官。我担任高级军官28年了。我负责过无数次演习。这些将军们关于所谓演习的说法，我简直不敢相信自己的耳朵。
All of this unfolds very quickly. Putin becomes prime minister in August. The bombings are in September. The war starts in September, also. Putin is the public face of the war, and it's going well. This is when his popularity soars.
这一切展开得非常快。普京在8月成为总理。爆炸案在9月。战争也在9月开始。普京是战争的公众面孔，进展顺利。这就是他声望飙升的时候。
[TRUMPET MUSIC]
[小号音乐]
And on New Year's Eve, at midnight, the president at the time, Boris Yeltsin, makes an announcement.
而在新年除夕午夜，当时的总统鲍里斯·叶利钦发表了一项声明。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Boris Yeltsin announces-- completes a shocking announcement that he's going to retire. He's going to resign the presidency, effective immediately. He names Vladimir Putin acting president. Putin's very first act, his very first presidential decree, is to stop all corruption investigations into Boris Yeltsin. These investigations had been going on. The elections are supposed to be in June. Instead, he moves them up to March, which gives opposition parties very little time to organize. And then he wins the presidency outright in March. So in this incredibly short period, about eight months, he goes from being a complete unknown to being the president of Russia.
鲍里斯·叶利钦宣布——完成了一项令人震惊的声明，他将退休。他将立即辞去总统职务。他任命弗拉基米尔·普京为代理总统。普京的第一个行动，他的第一个总统令，就是停止对鲍里斯·叶利钦的所有腐败调查。这些调查一直在进行。选举本应在6月举行。相反，他将选举提前到3月，这使反对党几乎没有时间进行组织。然后在3月，他彻底赢得了总统职位。所以在这短短的时间里，大约八个月，他从一个完全的陌生人变成了俄罗斯总统。
Maura Reynolds says when Ryazan happened, she saw it in local news reports, but it wasn't a huge story. The FSB may or may not have planted explosives. It wasn't clear what it meant. And it was quickly drowned out by the invasion and the war. Only in retrospect did it start to seem significant. And in retrospect, there were other pieces of evidence that started to seem important. I'll tell you one more.
莫拉·雷诺兹说，当梁赞事件发生时，她在当地新闻报道中看到了，但那不是什么大新闻。FSB可能放置了炸药，也可能没有。这究竟意味着什么并不清楚。而且它很快被入侵和战争淹没了。只有在回顾时，它才开始显得重要。回顾过去，还有其他证据开始显得重要。我再告诉你一个。
Right after one of the bombs went off in Moscow-- this was the third bomb-- the speaker of the Russian Parliament, a guy named Seleznyov, mentioned the bomb but got the city wrong. Mind you, he was in Moscow and the bomb was in Moscow. But he said the bomb went off in Volgodonsk. Here's Scott Anderson.
就在莫斯科其中一枚炸弹爆炸后——这是第三枚炸弹——俄罗斯议会议长，一个叫谢列兹尼奥夫的人，提到了炸弹，但说错了城市。请注意，他在莫斯科，炸弹也在莫斯科。但他却说炸弹在伏尔戈顿斯克爆炸了。这是斯科特·安德森。
So you could say, oh, well, somehow he said Volgodonsk instead of Moscow, except that three days later, an apartment building in Volgodonsk was blown up.
所以你可以说，哦，好吧，不知何故他说了伏尔戈顿斯克而不是莫斯科，除非三天后，伏尔戈顿斯克的一栋公寓大楼被炸毁。
Wow.
哇。
Raising the question of how Seleznyov knew about the bombing three days ahead of time.
提出了一个问题，即谢列兹尼奥夫是如何提前三天知道爆炸的。
The next thing that happens is--
接下来发生的事情是——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
After the bomb finally did go off in Volgodonsk, another member of parliament, a guy named Zhirinovsky, confronts the speaker about how suspicious this looks. He says, you told us on Monday that a building in Volgodonsk was blown up, three days before the explosion.
在伏尔戈顿斯克炸弹最终爆炸后，另一位议会议员，一个叫日里诺夫斯基的人，就这件事看起来有多可疑与议长对质。他说，你在周一告诉我们伏尔戈顿斯克的一栋楼被炸了，这可是爆炸发生前三天。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Zhirinovsky calls the act monstrous and says he'll try to keep the speaker from being re-elected, but he's hard to hear because they keep cutting his microphone off. Someone calls Zhirinovsky a scumbag, and then a scoundrel who deserves to be shot. Finally, Zhirinovsky turns around, walks away, and gets hit in the back with a folder of papers.
日里诺夫斯基称这种行为是怪物般的，并表示他会试图阻止议长连任，但他很难听到声音，因为他们一直切断他的麦克风。有人称日里诺夫斯基是人渣，然后是一个该死的无赖，应该被枪毙。最后，日里诺夫斯基转身走开，被一个文件夹砸在背上。
There was an official government investigation into the apartment bombings. Trials, convictions, all held in private, not open to the public or press. People were convicted. They were not FSB agents. They were not Chechens, either. There have been people outside the government who tried to look deeper into the bombings, but overall, that hasn't gone well. Most notably, an independent commission of human rights activists, politicians, and investigators. Again, Scott.
政府对公寓爆炸案进行了正式调查。审判、定罪，都在私下进行，不对公众或媒体开放。有人被定罪了。他们不是FSB特工。他们也不是车臣人。政府之外有人试图深入调查爆炸案，但总的来说，进展并不顺利。最著名的是一个由人权活动家、政治家和调查人员组成的独立委员会。再次提到斯科特。
The head of that commission was killed-- was murdered, shot to death in front of his house. Another member of the committee died under mysterious circumstances. Anna Politkovskaya, investigative journalist, one of Russia's leading investigative journalists, was murdered in her apartment building. She had written casting doubts on the apartment building bombings. And of course, Alexander Litvinenko came out publicly accusing the Putin regime of doing the apartment building bombings. He is poisoned with polonium in London in 2006 and dies.
那个委员会的负责人被杀害了——被谋杀了，在他家门前被枪杀。委员会的另一名成员在神秘的情况下死亡。安娜·波利特科夫斯卡娅，调查记者，俄罗斯最领先的调查记者之一，在她公寓楼里被杀。她写文章对公寓大楼爆炸案表示怀疑。当然，亚历山大·利特维年科公开站出来指责普京政权制造了公寓大楼爆炸案。他于2006年在伦敦被钋中毒身亡。
Radioactive poison. Polonium-210 slipped into his tea. A British investigation determined two FSB agents had killed Litvinenko, and that Putin had likely signed off on it.
放射性毒药。钋-210被偷偷放入他的茶中。英国的一项调查认定两名FSB特工杀害了利特维年科，而且普京很可能签署了批准令。
In his autobiography, which came out in 2000, Putin roundly denied any FSB involvement in the bombings, writing, quote, "What? Blowing up our own apartment buildings? You know, that is really utter nonsense. It's totally insane. No one in the Russian special services would be capable of such a crime against his own people," unquote.
在2000年出版的自传中，普京全面否认了FSB在爆炸案中的任何参与，写道，引述：“什么？炸毁我们自己的公寓大楼？你知道，那真是彻头彻尾的胡说八道。这完全是疯了。俄罗斯特种部队中没有人会对自己的国民做出这种罪行，”引述结束。
David Satter has been researching this since it happened and has written two books about it. He's convinced the story went like this. Before the bombings, even before Putin came to power, Boris Yeltsin and his administration were plagued with corruption investigations. He worried they could eventually point to him and his family, especially if some other party or someone unsympathetic to him became president. So he looked to appoint a prime minister who he could trust. He fired two other guys in just three months before landing on Putin. Then he and Putin together had the apartments blown up as the pretext to go to war, and, in the patriotic glow, to install Putin and quash the corruption investigations.
大卫·萨特自事件发生以来一直在研究此事，并为此写了两本书。他确信故事是这样的。在爆炸发生前，甚至在普京上台之前，鲍里斯·叶利钦和他的政府就深受腐败调查的困扰。他担心这些调查最终会指向他和他的家人，特别是如果其他政党或对他不赞同的人成为总统。所以他寻求任命一个他可以信任的总理。他在三个月内解雇了另外两名人员，才最终选定普京。然后他和普京一起炸毁了公寓，作为发动战争的借口，并在爱国主义的感召下，扶持普京上台并平息腐败调查。
Scott and Maura aren't so sure. For Maura, when it comes to the bombings, she gets that something was done by design and that it appears to be for political purposes. But as for who was behind the bombings exactly, she can't tell.
斯科特和莫拉不太确定。对莫拉来说，当谈到爆炸案时，她明白这是为了政治目的而设计的，似乎是有预谋的。但至于到底是谁在幕后策划，她说不准。
If you ask me what I think, I have to say, to this day, I do not know. But this is what I would say. Right now, it doesn't matter.
如果你问我怎么看，我不得不说，直到今天，我都不知道。但我会这样说。现在，这不重要了。
What do you mean?
你是什么意思？
Because whether the government or people around Putin played a role or whether they didn't, the effect is the same. Either you believe what they said about the bombings, that there were terrorists out to kill ordinary Russians, in which case you are frightened and the world is a very scary place; or you believe that your government or someone connected to the government could be bloody-minded enough to kill 300 innocent civilians in their beds, in which case the world is a very scary place and you should be frightened. This is how it works in a police state. You should be frightened. And that's how the government exercises control.
因为无论政府或普京周围的人是否扮演了角色，结果都是一样的。要么你相信他们关于爆炸的说法，即有恐怖分子出来杀害普通俄罗斯人，在这种情况下，你会感到恐惧，世界是一个非常可怕的地方；或者你相信你的政府或与政府有关的人可能丧心病狂到在睡梦中杀害300名无辜平民，在这种情况下，世界是一个非常可怕的地方，你应该感到恐惧。这就是警察国家运作的方式。你应该感到恐惧。这就是政府行使控制的方式。
It's been nearly two decades since the bombings and I wanted to know what do people in Russia think about them? Putin is still their president. How big a deal are they? Are people walking around, wondering if their president came to power by killing hundreds of Russian citizens? So I interviewed four people who live in Moscow.
爆炸案已经过去了近二十年，我想知道俄罗斯人现在是怎么想的？普京仍然是他们的总统。它们有多重要？人们走在大街上，会想他们的总统是否是通过杀害数百名俄罗斯公民而上台的吗？所以我采访了住在莫斯科的四个人。
None of them said they were big supporters of Putin. Three of the four had heard the rumor that he was behind the bombings. None of them believed it or wanted to believe it. "I can't know the truth, so I can't say," a 42-year-old screenwriter told me. A 22-year-old student I talked to said she didn't want to know if it was true.
他们中没有一个人说自己是普京的铁杆支持者。四个人中有三个听过他是爆炸案幕后黑手的谣言。没有一个人相信或愿意相信。一位42岁的编剧告诉我，“我不知道真相，所以我不能说。”我交谈的一位22岁学生说她不想知道这是不是真的。
As for Ryazan, only one of the four, a telecommunications specialist, had heard anything about Ryazan, the sacks of sugar, any of that. He knew all the details, though. Read a book about it. And he believes Ryazan was an FSB drill.
至于梁赞，四人中只有一个，一名电信专家，听说过关于梁赞、糖袋或任何这类事情。但他知道所有细节。读过一本关于此的书。他相信梁赞是一次FSB演习。
The one person who'd never heard the story that Putin might be behind the bombings was Yuliya, a 40-year-old lawyer.
唯一一个没听说过普京可能是爆炸案幕后黑手的故事的人是尤利娅，一位40岁的律师。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
It's just not something that people discuss. The media doesn't say anything about it. The families don't talk to each other about this. And friends don't talk about this to each other.
这根本不是人们讨论的事情。媒体对此只字不提。家庭成员之间不谈论这个。朋友之间也不谈论这个。
Does it just seem like old news?
这看起来像是旧闻了吗？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Yes, absolutely.
是的，绝对是的。
So I ran through all the facts with her, all the evidence that Putin might be behind the bombings. She said she didn't care. Does it sound like a ridiculous theory, I asked. Yes, she said. Most likely. Some ridiculous theory.
所以我跟她过了所有事实，所有普京可能是爆炸案幕后黑手的证据。她说她不在乎。我问，这听起来像是个荒谬的理论吗？她说，是的。极有可能。一些荒谬的理论。
Robyn Semien.
罗宾·塞米恩。
Act Two, Mr. Popular.
第二幕，受欢迎先生。
So here in the United States, we're told that Vladimir Putin is incredibly popular in Russia, and the statistic you see sometimes in the press is that he has an 84% approval rating among Russians, which, of course, is insanely high. We think US presidents are doing great when they get to 55% or 60%. But that 84%, is that real? Is that just from some Russian state agency that is controlled by Putin?
在美国，我们被告知弗拉基米尔·普京在俄罗斯非常受欢迎，你在媒体上看到的统计数字是他拥有84%的俄罗斯人支持率，这当然高得不可思议。我们认为美国总统能达到55%或60%就已经做得不错了。但那84%是真的吗？这只是来自某些受普京控制的俄罗斯国家机构的数据吗？
Well, we asked Charles Maynes to look into this for us. He's an American radio producer based in Moscow.
好吧，我们请查尔斯·梅恩斯帮我们调查一下。他是常驻莫斯科的美国电台制作人。
Charles, is that number real?
查尔斯，那个数字是真的吗？
Well, it is real. These are real polls, where large numbers of real people really do answer questions. Russia has two big polling firms that are essentially state-sponsored and one that's independent. And all three of these get basically the same numbers. This month, Putin dropped by 2% to 82%. And American pollsters like Gallup and Pew, they also get the same results.
好吧，它是真的。这些是真实的民调，大量真实的人确实回答了问题。俄罗斯有两个大型民调公司基本上是国家资助的，还有一个是独立的。这三家公司得到的数字基本相同。本月，普京的支持率下降了2%，至82%。而像盖洛普和皮尤这样的美国民调机构，他们也得到了同样的结果。
In the 80s?
在80%多？
Yeah, in the 80s.
是的，在80%多。
But are people just saying that they like Putin because they are scared to say anything else?
但人们说喜欢普京，仅仅是因为他们不敢说别的吗？
Well, that's part of it, especially with older people. There was a poll done by this Levada Center-- this is the independent pollster in Russia-- saying that 26% of all respondents said they're afraid to share their views of the government with pollsters. So that probably inflates the number, but just how much isn't really clear.
好吧，这部分是肯定的，尤其是对老年人来说。俄罗斯独立民调机构列瓦达中心进行的一项民调显示，26%的所有受访者表示他们不敢与民调人员分享他们对政府的看法。所以这可能会夸大数字，但夸大多少还不清楚。
So if 82% isn't the right number, do we have any sense of what a more accurate measure of his popularity might be?
所以，如果82%不是准确的数字，我们是否对他的受欢迎程度有一个更准确的衡量标准？
Some pollsters say it's the so-called electoral rating. This is when you ask Russians who they'd actually vote for. Like The Levada Center has this poll they do where they say, if the presidential elections were held next Sunday, who would you vote for? And then only 55% say they'd vote for Putin. And that's, again, the independent pollsters. The state one has a figure that's a little higher-- 64%-- but that's hardly the 82%, 84% that we've seen.
一些民调机构说这是所谓的选举支持率。当你问俄罗斯人他们实际上会投谁的票时。比如列瓦达中心做的民调显示，如果下周日举行总统大选，你会投谁？那么只有55%的人说他们会投票给普京。这依然是独立民调机构的数据。国家机构的数据稍微高一点——64%——但这绝不是我们看到的82%、84%。
So what I get from this is, take the 82%, 84% approval rating with a grain of salt, but it is true that most people approve of him?
所以我从这里得出的结论是，对82%、84%的支持率持怀疑态度，但大多数人支持他是真的？
Yeah. He's still really popular.
是的。他依然非常受欢迎。
OK. So to hear what that approval is all about and what people think of him, we asked you to talk to some people who like him, which you did. People across the country. And then you put together this story about one of them.
好的。为了了解这种支持率到底是怎么回事，以及人们怎么看他，我们请你采访了一些喜欢他的人，你确实做了。全国各地的人。然后你整理了这个关于其中一个人的故事。
This was someone I knew wouldn't exaggerate their feelings about the president because they were talking to a foreign reporter, someone I've known for decades.
我知道这个人不会夸大她对总统的感受，因为她在和一位外国记者交谈，这是我认识了几十年的一个人。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
That's her talking here, Olga Sergeevna Dmitrieva. I lived with Olga Sergeevna and her two children back in the mid-'90s, when I was an exchange student in Moscow. It was a good five years before Putin arrived on the scene. Over the years, she took in several American exchange students.
说话的是奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜·德米特里耶娃。90年代中期，当我在莫斯科做交换生时，我曾和奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜及她的两个孩子住在一起。那是普京出现前整整五年。多年来，她收留了几位美国交换生。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
That's her telling me I was her favorite. And I tell her I always say I have a Russian mom.
她在告诉我我是她最喜欢的。我告诉她我总是说我有一个俄罗斯妈妈。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
She says, I always say I have an American son, who I don't see as much as I like.
她说，我总是说我有一个美国儿子，我没能像我希望的那样经常见到他。
We took the tram to her apartment building through the neighborhood I lived in with her family back in the '90s, and she started pointing out all these changes. A new playground, new stores. And just by the new museum, they're building a community pool. Now, none of this was here back when I lived with them. It's all part of the prosperity that's come to Moscow since Putin came to power. And it's why Olga Sergeevna and lots of people in her generation-- she's in her 60s-- it's why they love Putin.
我们坐电车穿过我90年代和她家人住过的街区去她的公寓，她开始指出所有这些变化。一个新的操场，新的商店。就在博物馆旁边，他们正在建一个社区游泳池。现在，我和他们住在一起时，这些都没有。这都是自普京上台以来莫斯科繁荣的一部分。这就是为什么奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜和她那一代许多人——她60多岁了——这也是为什么他们爱普京。
When I lived with Olga Sergeevna and her family, Boris Yeltsin was president and things in Russia were really, really tough. In fact, there's a poll for that. It says 68% of Russians think nothing good happened in Russia during the Yeltsin years. Nothing.
当我和奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜一家住在一起时，鲍里斯·叶利钦是总统，俄罗斯的情况真的非常非常糟糕。事实上，有一个民调证实了这一点。68%的俄罗斯人认为叶利钦执政期间俄罗斯没发生过任何好事。什么都没有。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Olga Sergeevna says life was hard back then. People didn't have enough money. Grocery stores were empty. And they only began to clear with the arrival of Vladimir Putin. It seems almost hard to remember now, but when Putin first arrived as prime minister in 1999, Russians had no idea who he was. He was this awkward public speaker back then. His suits were ill-fitting. The guy never smiled.
奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜说那时候生活很艰难。人们没有足够的钱。杂货店是空的。直到弗拉基米尔·普京到来，它们才开始清空。现在看来几乎很难记得了，但当普京在1999年首次担任总理时，俄罗斯人根本不知道他是谁。那时候他是个笨拙的公众演讲者。他的西装很不合身。这家伙从不笑。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Hardly, says Olga Sergeevna, the specimen she sees now. She told me Putin's appearance was predicted earlier, when mystics said one day a man named Volodya would save Russia. Volodya is short for Vladimir. Lots of the older generation will tell you stuff like this.
很难想象，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜说，她现在看到的样本。她告诉我普京的出现是早先预言的，神秘主义者说有一天一个叫沃洛佳的人会拯救俄罗斯。沃洛佳是弗拉基米尔的简称。许多老一辈人会告诉你这样的事。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Nobody thought that savior would be Putin. I mean, let's face it, she says. He's kind of short. No one believed he'd change Russia. That Russia would rise from its knees. But it did rise from its knees. His predecessor, Boris Yeltsin, was seen as this buffoon, visibly drunk in meetings with world leaders. An embarrassment.
没人想到那个救世主会是普京。我是说，让我们面对现实吧，她说。他有点矮。没人相信他会改变俄罗斯。俄罗斯会从膝盖上站起来。但它确实站起来了。他的前任，鲍里斯·叶利钦，被视为一个小丑，在与世界领导人的会议上明显喝醉了。令人尴尬。
Putin was younger. He didn't drink. The fact that he was a former KGB agent at least meant he was disciplined and educated. He spoke German, practiced judo. And he brought an end to the chaos of the Yeltsin years, during which the ruble had collapsed several times. The government was constantly reshuffled. And a few insiders, the so-called oligarchs, became billionaires while most everyone else lost their savings.
普京更年轻。他不喝酒。他曾是克格勃特工这一事实至少意味着他纪律严明且受过教育。他会说德语，练习柔道。他结束了叶利钦时代的混乱，期间卢布曾多次崩溃。政府不断改组。少数内部人士，所谓的寡头，成为了亿万富翁，而大多数其他人失去了积蓄。
But as soon as Putin took over, the economy boomed, mostly because of oil prices shooting up. And soon he exiled or arrested oligarchs who'd been running the country behind the scenes. A lot of people talk about how Putin saved Russia.
但普京一接手，经济就蓬勃发展，主要是因为油价飙升。很快，他流放或逮捕了在幕后经营国家的寡头。许多人谈论普京是如何拯救俄罗斯的。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
If you compare 1994 and 2017, Olga Sergeevna says, the difference is night and day. In 1994, '95, we didn't celebrate holidays. Nobody was in a festive mood. The theaters were all closed because nobody went. Nobody had money.
如果你比较1994年和2017年，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜说，区别是天壤之别。在1994年、95年，我们不过节。没人有节日气氛。剧院都关门了，因为没人去。没人有钱。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Under Putin, she says, she lives a comfortable life, has a job, can afford to travel, can go out to eat or to the theater. It's hard to overstate how important this is. During Putin's first decade in power, Russians had never lived better, particularly in the bigger cities. People like Olga Sergeevna became part of something that was happening for the first time ever in Russia-- the emergence of the middle class.
在普京治下，她说，她过着舒适的生活，有工作，负担得起旅行，可以出去吃饭或去看戏。很难夸大这一点的重要性。在普京掌权的头十年，俄罗斯人的生活从未像现在这样好，特别是在大城市。像奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜这样的人成为了俄罗斯有史以来第一次发生的事情的一部分——中产阶级的崛起。
Over time, this economic miracle turned Putin into sort of a folk hero. There's the side of him we know in America, the guy flying jets or riding horses shirtless. But in Russia, he's cultivated this image that he's frugal, lives modestly, works all the time. A political analyst told me Putin's seen as the only one who can fix anything or improve people's lives, the one who keeps corrupt bureaucrats in check. He's the good czar. For Olga Sergeevna, it wasn't just that Putin made the country better. It was that he could do no wrong.
随着时间的推移，这种经济奇迹把普京变成了一种民间英雄。他在美国那一面我们知道，开着喷气式飞机或赤膊骑马。但在俄罗斯，他精心营造了一种形象，即他节俭、生活朴素、整天工作。一位政治分析家告诉我，普京被视为唯一能解决任何问题或改善人们生活的人，是那个控制腐败官僚的人。他是好沙皇。对奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜来说，不仅仅是普京让国家变得更好。而是他不会犯错。
I love Putin.
我爱普京。
Why?
为什么？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Because he's smart, intelligent, cultured, athletic, she says. He's even a musician, plays and sings.
因为他聪明、有智慧、有教养、有运动天赋，她说。他甚至是个音乐家，会演奏和唱歌。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
I asked her if there's anything he can't do. Her response?
我问她有什么是他不会做的吗？她的回答？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
He can't cook. But he doesn't need to. Finally, I said, come on. Isn't there anything you don't like about him? Anything at all?
他不会做饭。但他不需要。最后，我说，拜托。就没有什么你不喜欢他的地方吗？一点点？
Nyet. Nyet. Nyet. Nyet! No!
不。不。不。不！没有！
While we were talking, Olga Sergeevna brought me over to her computer, started scrolling through her Facebook page. She subscribes to a Putin feed just to see what he's up to. And her feed is filled with pictures of him. Putin snarling. Putin laughing. Doesn't he look like a benevolent lord, she says.
当我们谈话时，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜带我走到她的电脑前，开始滚动她的Facebook页面。她订阅了普京的动态，只是为了看看他在做什么。她的信息流里全是他的照片。普京咆哮着。普京笑着。他不看起来像位慈祥的领主吗，她说。
I just want to point out here that Olga Sergeevna doesn't work for the government or Putin's United Russia party. She's an accountant. She has been for decades. With a daughter who lives in London and a son who works for an American tech company.
我只想指出一点，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜不为政府或普京的统一俄罗斯党工作。她是一名会计师。她已经做了几十年了。她的女儿住在伦敦，儿子在一家美国科技公司工作。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
One of the things Olga Sergeevna likes best is that Putin stands up to the West. And that's a big thing for Russians.
奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜最喜欢的事情之一是普京挺身对抗西方。这对俄罗斯人来说是一件大事。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
As Putin likes to say, when they curse me in the West, it means I'm doing the right thing.
正如普京喜欢说的，当他们在西方咒骂我时，意味着我做得是对的。
When it comes to the bad things Americans hear about Putin-- that he's corrupt, that he's secretly one of the world's richest men, or that he's meddled in the American elections-- Olga Sergeevna says that's all lies perpetuated by Western journalists. People like me. A reminder that we have this ongoing joke, where she tells me to leave our Putin alone, and she says she means it.
当谈到美国人听到的关于普京的坏事时——他腐败，他是世界上最富有的人之一，或者他干预了美国大选——奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜说那是西方记者 perpetuating（散布）的谎言。像我这样的人。提醒我们有一个持续的笑话，她让我别管我们的普京，她说她是认真的。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
I ask her about the many opponents of Putin's who've ended up dead. The journalist Anna Politkovskaya or Alexander Litvinenko, the KGB whistleblower who was poisoned with a radioactive isotope. Who poisoned him, she asks. Some say it was Putin, I tell her. Oh, please. Everyone says it's Putin.
我问她关于普京的许多死去的对手。记者安娜·波利特科夫斯卡娅或亚历山大·利特维年科，那个被放射性同位素毒死的克格勃揭秘者。是谁毒死他的，她问。我告诉她，有些人说是普京。哦，求你了。每个人都说是普京。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
The moment somebody sneezes or farts in Russia, Putin is to blame. I say, but what about the opposition leader Boris Nemtsov? He was killed. But she interrupts me and says--
在俄罗斯，有人打喷嚏或放屁，都要怪普京。我说，但反对派领袖鲍里斯·涅姆佐夫呢？他被杀了。但她打断我说——
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
Nothing of the sort. Nothing of the sort. There was an investigation. Nemtsov died over a love triangle. She doesn't buy any of it. In fact, a lot of Olga Sergeevna's opinions are things you might hear on state TV. But I think with Olga Sergeevna, and the other people I talk to-- people who love Putin-- the moments I understand them best are when they talk about the past, everything they went through before Putin arrived. It's why sometimes I think the real reason people like Putin is not because they believe he'll keep moving Russia forward into the future. It's because they fear someone else-- anyone else-- might drive Russia back to the past.
根本没那回事。根本没那回事。有调查的。涅姆佐夫死于三角恋。她根本不买账。事实上，奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜的许多观点都是你在国家电视台可能听到的。但我认为对奥尔加·谢尔盖耶夫娜和其他我交谈过的人——那些爱普京的人来说——我最理解他们的时刻是当他们谈论过去时，谈论普京到来之前他们经历的一切。这就是为什么有时我认为人们喜欢普京的真正原因不是因为他们相信他会推动俄罗斯走向未来。是因为他们担心别人——随便什么人——可能会把俄罗斯带回过去。
Charles Maynes in Moscow. Coming up, the Steve Bannon of the Kremlin, except he accomplishes all kinds of stuff and is not on the verge of losing his job. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
莫斯科的查尔斯·梅恩斯。接下来，克里姆林宫的史蒂夫·班农，除了他完成了各种各样的事情，并且没有面临失去工作的危险。那是芝加哥公共广播电台的一分钟内容，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program, The Other Mr. President, stories of Vladimir Putin and those around him.
这里是《这就是美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，《另一位总统先生》，关于弗拉基米尔·普京和他周围人的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three of our program. Act Three, Maybe Pay a Little Attention to the Man Behind the Curtain.
我们到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，也许稍微关注一下幕后操纵者。
There's a quote that we heard while we were working on today's program from a writer named Peter Pomerantsev. He said that if the old Soviet Union was 75% violence, 25% propaganda, in today's Russia, those numbers are reversed. It's 25% violence and 75% propaganda. Propaganda was radically reinvented under Vladimir Putin, its tactics and its methods, by this one political operative. Sean Cole explains.
我们在制作今天的节目时听到了作家彼得·波美兰采夫的一句话。他说，如果说前苏联是75%的暴力，25%的宣传，那么在今天的俄罗斯，这些数字是反过来的。是25%的暴力和75%的宣传。宣传在弗拉基米尔·普京治下得到了彻底的重塑，它的战术和方法，是由这位政治操盘手实现的。肖恩·科尔解释说。
The operative's name is Vladislav Surkov. He was Putin's deputy chief for more than a decade, starting in 1999. In Russia, he's what's referred to as a political technologist. But those are a dime a dozen. At the top of his powers, Surkov had a much more ominous, if unofficial, title. He was known as a grey cardinal.
操盘手的名字是弗拉季斯拉夫·苏尔科夫。他担任普京的副幕僚长十多年，从1999年开始。在俄罗斯，他被称为政治技术专家。但这种人多如牛毛。在他权力的顶峰时期，苏尔科夫有一个更不祥的，虽然是非官方的头衔。他被称为“灰衣主教”。
He doesn't look like a shadowy mastermind. He sort of resembles Rowan Atkinson, the actor who played Mr. Bean, except handsomer. And he actually doesn't manage propaganda at the Kremlin anymore. But the methods he invented to manipulate people and information, I've even heard them called artistic.
他看起来不像个阴暗的主谋。他长得有点像演员罗温·艾金森，那个扮演“憨豆先生”的人，除了更英俊点。他实际上不再在克里姆林宫管理宣传了。但他发明的操纵人和信息的方法，我甚至听说它们被称为艺术。
See, in the Soviet era, the country was run by the Communist Party and the propagandists pumped out literally the party line and tried to suppress all other opposing messages. And then the Iron Curtain fell. A whole bunch of new political parties were created. And it was the messy early stages of a real democracy, with parties bickering and vying for power.
你看，在苏联时代，国家由共产党领导，宣传人员字面上泵出党的声音，并试图压制所有其他反对信息。然后铁幕倒下了。创造了一大堆新的政党。这是真正民主的混乱早期阶段，政党吵架并争夺权力。
And then, when Putin became president-- I'm obviously skipping over a lot here-- his right-hand man, Surkov, helped solidify the Kremlin's power by putting together this party called United Russia, which gained a majority in Parliament and backed Putin. And then, instead of tamping down the opposition like the old days, Surkov built a new system, where there was opposition, but he dictated what the opposition stood for.
然后，当普京成为总统时——我显然跳过了很多东西——他的得力助手苏尔科夫通过组建一个名为“统一俄罗斯”的政党巩固了克里姆林宫的权力，该党在议会中获得了多数席位并支持普京。然后，苏尔科夫没有像过去那样压制反对派，而是建立了一个新系统，有反对派，但他决定了反对派代表什么。
You do not allow political parties to create their own agendas. You just write these agendas for them.
你不允许政党创造自己的议程。你只需要为他们写这些议程。
This is Vasily Gatov. He's been a very high-level player in Russian media for nearly 20 years. These days, he's a visiting fellow at the Annenberg Center on Communication, Leadership, and Policy.
这是瓦西里·加托夫。他近20年来一直是俄罗斯媒体界的高层人物。这些天，他是安纳伯格传播、领导力和政策中心的一位访问学者。
We decide one of our parties is left party with some sort of communism. Another party, you're a socialist. And the third party is a deep conservative, kind of evangelicals. And the fourth party would be liberal radicals. And that's what Surkov actually constructed.
我们决定我们的政党之一是左翼政党，带点共产主义。另一个政党，你是社会主义者。第三个政党是深度保守派，有点像福音派。第四个政党是自由激进派。这就是苏尔科夫实际构建的东西。
And he created whole new political parties and wrote their agendas.
他创造了全新的政党并编写了他们的议程。
For example, he created a party called Spravedlivaya Rossiya. Just Russia.
例如，他创造了一个叫“公正俄罗斯”的党。公正俄罗斯。
Just Russia.
公正俄罗斯。
Yeah. That was a political cadaver.
是的。那是一个政治尸体。
Are you saying cadaver, like a corpse?
你是说尸体，像个死尸？
Cadaver, like a cadaver.
尸体，像个尸体。
Like Frankenstein.
像弗兰肯斯坦。
Frankenstein, yeah.
弗兰肯斯坦，是的。
Got it.
明白了。
Created from some sort of pieces of socialists, labor, activists, more pro-government type of labor unions. He also decided that he cannot allow any grassroot activities which would not be vetted by the Kremlin, so he decided that he will create also youth movements and write an agenda for them. And he also tried to do the same thing with NGOs, like political NGOs or those that control elections' transparency or expose corruption-- writing agendas for every one of them in the Kremlin.
用一些社会主义者、劳工、活动家、更亲政府类型的工会的碎片创造出来的。他还决定他不能允许任何未经克里姆林宫审核的基层活动，所以他决定他也将创造青年运动并为他们编写议程。他还试图对NGO做同样的事情，比如政治NGO，或者那些控制选举透明度或揭露腐败的组织——在克里姆林宫为他们每一个编写议程。
It's like directing a movie, in a way.
这在某种程度上就像导演电影。
Absolutely. I would even provide you with a very funny hypothesis. In 2001, I think, Russia has been invaded by reality shows, things like Survivor, Big Brother. And he was amazed how scripting can improve even those likely spontaneous interactions between people. And I know that he was very good friends with all the producers of these reality shows, actually. And actually, I think he was once even present at the filming of the Russian version of Survivor.
绝对。我甚至可以给你一个非常有趣的假设。我想在2001年，俄罗斯被真人秀节目入侵了，比如《幸存者》、《老大哥》。他很惊讶脚本能如何改善那些本来可能是自发的人际互动。我知道他和所有这些真人秀节目的制片人关系很好，事实上。而且我认为他甚至曾经在俄罗斯版《幸存者》的拍摄现场出现过。
No way.
没门。
Yeah.
是的。
And he's like, if they can do that on TV, sort of fake reality in TV, maybe we can fake reality in reality?
他就像，如果他们能在电视上那样做，电视上的假现实，也许我们能在现实中假造现实？
In a way, yeah.
在某种程度上，是的。
By 2003-- so about four years into Surkov's tenure as grey cardinal-- Vasily says Surkov had built up a whole cadre of deputies that would carry out his agenda with these different parties and other groups. I asked Vasily for an example of how all this worked, and he told me what everybody told me when I asked for specifics. He said, it's not like I was in the room with him. I don't know exactly what he said to whom, nor when.
到了2003年——即苏尔科夫担任灰衣主教四年后——瓦西里说苏尔科夫建立了一整套副手架构，他们将通过这些不同的政党和其他团体来实现他的议程。我向瓦西里询问这到底是怎么运作的例子，他告诉我当我在问细节时每个人都告诉我的话。他说，并不是说我跟他呆在一个房间里。我不知道他确切对谁说了什么，也不知何时。
He did tell me about this one case that he heard about from someone who worked with Surkov. In 2004, Vladimir Putin decided that governors shouldn't be elected anymore. They should be appointed by him. It's a long story, but at first, every other political party besides Putin's was against the idea. Genuinely against it. But then Surkov manipulated them over to his side. It helped that he controlled their funding and the number of seats they got in the Duma.
他确实告诉了我这个他从和苏尔科夫共事过的人那里听来的案子。2004年，弗拉基米尔·普京决定不再选举州长。他们应该由他任命。这是一个长故事，但起初，除了普京之外的每个政党都反对这个想法。确实反对。但苏尔科夫把他们操纵到他的一边。他控制了他们的资金和他们在杜马中获得的席位，这很有帮助。
And then the parties went through this whole drawn-out public drama, which had all the trappings of democracy. The bill was submitted. There were arguments for and against it. Protests around the country. People announced they've changed their minds. There were several votes. And finally, after three months, it passes. All of this, Vasily says, was scripted by Surkov's people.
然后各方经历了这场冗长的公开闹剧，具有民主的所有特征。法案提交了。有赞成和反对的争论。全国各地的抗议活动。人们宣布他们改变了主意。进行了几次投票。最终，在三个月后，它通过了。瓦西里说，这一切都是苏尔科夫的人写好的脚本。
The name you hear for all these techniques is managed democracy. Surkov uses the phrase sovereign democracy. I suggested to one person I talked to that managed democracy sounds like a contradiction in terms. He said, exactly. It just means there's no democracy.
你听到所有这些技术的名字是“管理民主”。苏尔科夫使用“主权民主”这个词。我向我交谈过的一个人建议，“管理民主”听起来像是一个术语上的矛盾。他说，正是。那只是意味着没有民主。
I don't want to overstate Surkov's power, nor his malevolence. Apparently, he was much more carrot than stick in his approach in explaining why, no, you really want to align yourself with the Kremlin. Here's what's to be gained. And he didn't try to do this with everybody.
我不想夸大苏尔科夫的权力，也不想夸大他的恶意。显然，他在解释为什么——不，你真的想与克里姆林宫结盟——时，他的方法是萝卜多于大棒。这里有可以获得的东西。他没有试图对每个人都这样做。
He maintained, under this managed or sovereign democracy, a certain level of dissent.
他在这种管理或主权民主下，保持了一定程度的异议。
Some actual opposition.
一些实际的反对派。
Actual opposition, both in society and press, and even enjoyed this dissent because it was developing natural leaders like Navalny.
实际的反对派，无论在社会还是媒体中，甚至享受这种异议，因为它正在培养像纳瓦尔尼这样的天然领袖。
That's Alexei Navalny. You may have heard of him. He's a high-profile activist, organized the anti-corruption protests in Russia a few weeks ago. He is considered to be the only real opponent to Putin, except he can't run against Putin because Putin's people had him arrested, and you can't run for president in Russia if you have a criminal record.
那是阿列克谢·纳瓦尔尼。你可能听说过他。他是位高调的活动家，几周前在俄罗斯组织了反腐败抗议活动。他被认为是普京唯一的真正对手，除了他不能竞选普京，因为普京的人逮捕了他，而且如果你有犯罪记录，你在俄罗斯不能竞选总统。
To be honest, Navalny emerged within these sandboxes of allowed freedom that Surkov created, and it was important for him because it was making his camouflage of autocracy much better-looking.
老实说，纳瓦尔尼出现在这些苏尔科夫创造的允许自由的沙盒中，这对他很重要，因为它让他的独裁伪装看起来好多了。
The more you hear about Surkov the man, the more it makes you understand how his whole Truman Show theatrical directing of society developed. He has all of these opposing factions inside of him, too, all working in an unlikely but perfect concert together.
关于苏尔科夫这个人听得越多，越让你明白他那整套“楚门的世界”般的社会导演是怎么发展的。他内心也有所有这些对立的派系，都在某种不可思议但完美的配合中一起运作。
Back in the early '90s, he was a PR guy, designing ads for the richest oligarch in Russia. At that point, Surkov said he wanted to be like, quote, "the hero in Pretty Woman." He meant the Richard Gere character. But he's also a huge fan of the anti-bureaucracy, gay, Buddhist, beat poet, Allen Ginsberg. This is Surkov reciting Ginsberg's poem "Sunflower Sutra" from memory.
早在90年代初，他是个公关人员，为俄罗斯最富有的寡头设计广告。那时，苏尔科夫说他想成为，引述：“《漂亮女人》里的英雄。”他指的是理查·基尔的角色。但他也是反官僚、同性恋、佛教徒、垮掉派诗人艾伦·金斯伯格的超级粉丝。这是苏尔科夫背诵金斯伯格的诗《向日葵经》。
And you there standing before me in this sunset, and all your glory in your form. A perfect beauty of a sunflower.
你站在我面前的日落里，你那辉煌的形式中的所有荣耀。一朵完美的向日葵的美丽。
You might be able to tell that Surkov studied theater, but he got kicked out of the Moscow Institute of Culture after a fistfight. Reportedly. He's written lyrics for a Russian band called Agata Kristi. And so you marry PR and art and performance, plus his time at Russia's main state TV network, Channel One, managed democracy was just the natural culmination.
你可能看得出苏尔科夫学过戏剧，但他因打架被莫斯科文化学院开除了。据报道。他为一支叫“阿加莎·克里斯蒂”的俄罗斯乐队写过歌词。所以你把公关和艺术与表演结合起来，加上他在俄罗斯主要国家电视网络——第一频道的工作时间，管理民主只是自然的顶点。
He was kind of entertaining himself.
他有点在娱乐自己。
Again, Vasily Gatov.
再次提到瓦西里·加托夫。
It was really funny for him to make these things happen, to achieve certain results, and creative building of reality. Again, as I said, it's a very much Big Brother type of scripting.
让他这些事情发生，为了获得特定结果，以及创造性地构建现实，对他来说真的很有趣。再一次，正如我所说，这是非常“老大哥”类型的脚本。
He means the reality show Big Brother.
他指的是真人秀《老大哥》。
You need to create a conflict, and this conflict will create the conflict, and then we just roll it out and people will vote, and that would be fun.
你需要创造一个冲突，这个冲突将创造冲突，然后我们只是推出它，人们会投票，那会很有趣。
Besides which, he could totally get away with it because not only was he good at it, but in Surkov's time as grey cardinal, not very many people were paying attention.
此外，他可以完全逃脱惩罚，因为不仅他做得好，而且在苏尔科夫担任“灰衣主教”期间，没多少人在注意。
At this moment, people were absolutely uninterested in politics because Russia had a national economy growth of about 9% a year. The ruble was taking strength. Credit was extremely cheap. The country was booming. It's easy to build autocracy when a country's booming because nobody cares about politics.
此时，人们对政治完全不感兴趣，因为俄罗斯的国民经济增长每年约为9%。卢布在走强。信贷极其便宜。国家正在繁荣。当国家繁荣时，很容易建立独裁统治，因为没人关心政治。
Right.
对。
And I think Surkov was enjoying this moment because he was not only kind of a shadow cardinal, but he actually was openly cardinaling the situation.
我认为苏尔科夫当时很享受这一刻，因为他不仅是一个影子主教，而且他实际上在公开地掌控局势。
That is, after a certain point, he wouldn't take very many pains to hide what he was doing, which I can imagine the feeling. Here he is carrying off all of these feats of manipulation in secret. You'd think he'd want a little credit. On this point, there was a moment when Surkov seemed to be showing his cards a little bit, deliberately. It's a story that Peter Pomerantsev likes to tell. He's the journalist that Ira quoted earlier. Peter used to work in reality TV in Russia, and he's written a lot about Surkov.
也就是说，在某一点之后，他不会费太大劲去隐藏他在做什么，我可以想象那种感觉。在这里，他秘密地完成了所有这些操纵壮举。你会觉得他想得到一点认可。在这点上，有一个时刻苏尔科夫似乎有点故意展示了他的牌。这是一个彼得·波美兰采夫喜欢讲的故事。他是艾拉早先引述的记者。彼得以前在俄罗斯做真人秀电视，他写了很多关于苏尔科夫的文章。
This liberal blogger-- liberal photo blogger, yeah; the very, very popular blog-- took some photos of the office.
这位自由派博主——自由派照片博主，是的；非常、非常受欢迎的博客——拍了一些办公室的照片。
Of Surkov's office?
苏尔科夫的办公室？
Yeah, yeah.
是的，是的。
He was there to photograph an official meeting, but he said on his blog that he was much more interested in what was in the office.
他当时在那里拍摄一次官方会议，但他在博客上说，他对办公室里有什么更感兴趣。
And that's where you have the phones on his desk with the names of all the opposition political parties.
那就是你的办公桌上有所有反对派政党的电话。
Like literally, there's a whole mess of phones. And on one of them in particular, next to the numbers, there's a bank of buttons labeled "Mironov," "Zhirinovsky," "Zyuganov," all heads of parties.
字面上，有一大堆手机。其中特别是一部，在号码旁边，有一排标有“米罗诺夫”、“日里诺夫斯基”、“久加诺夫”的按钮，全是党魁。
And you have the photo of Tupac Shakur next to like Machiavelli or something.
还有图帕克·夏库尔的照片，旁边是马基雅维利之类的。
Yes, Tupac Shakur the rapper. It's actually next to a picture of Barack Obama.
是的，说唱歌手图帕克·夏库尔。它实际上是在巴拉克·奥巴马的照片旁边。
And at the time, everyone was like, oh my god, wow, we got to see inside Surkov's office. And then many years later, when everybody realized that Surkov had been funding this liberal blogger, everyone's like, oh my god, he leaked that. He wanted us to feel his power.
当时，每个人都说，哦我的天，哇，我们得以窥见苏尔科夫的办公室内部。然后多年后，当每个人意识到苏尔科夫一直在资助这个自由派博主时，每个人都说，哦我的天，是他泄露的。他想让我们感受到他的力量。
And he wanted to create an atmosphere where you can never really tell what's true anymore, so everything is suspect. That was absolutely intentional. Surkov himself has come just shy of saying it openly.
他想创造一种氛围，让你再也分不清什么是真的，所以一切都值得怀疑。那是绝对故意的。苏尔科夫本人已经差一点就公开说了。
He talks about it in his book.
他在他的书里谈到了这一点。
This is another shape Surkov is reported to have shifted into. He wrote a novel under the pseudonym Natan Dubovitsky. He won't admit it's really him, but Surkov's wife is named Natalya Dubovitskaya, so everyone's like, nutty coincidence. The book's called Almost Zero, or Close to Zero. It's about a PR guy who grew up in the sticks, like Surkov did, moved to Moscow to hang out with bohemian artists, like Surkov did, and is now embroiled in the seedy murderous underworld of illegal book publishing and distribution. Oh, and it's got an English subtitle-- "gangsta fiction."
这是苏尔科夫据称转化为的另一种形态。他以化名纳坦·杜博维茨基写了一本小说。他不承认那是他本人，但苏尔科夫的妻子叫娜塔莉亚·杜博维茨卡娅，所以每个人都说，疯狂的巧合。书名是《几乎为零》或《接近零》。这是关于一个公关人员的故事，他像苏尔科夫一样在偏远地区长大，搬到莫斯科与波西米亚艺术家混在一起，就像苏尔科夫做的那样，现在卷入了非法图书出版和发行的肮脏、凶杀的黑社会。哦，它还有一个英语副标题——“黑帮小说”。
In any case, Peter says there are these really telling passages in which the hero realizes, oh, wait. Everything's made up. Language, politics, every ideology-- everything's fake. I can see through it all. It's an epic kind of cynicism.
无论如何，彼得说书中有一些非常说明问题的段落，英雄意识到，哦，等等。一切都是编造的。语言、政治、每一种意识形态——一切都是假的。我能看穿这一切。这是一种史诗般的犬儒主义。
It's not cynicism as in like, oh, I don't believe in anything, but almost like, oh my god, I've burst through the shallow shells of morality and ideology and belief.
这不像犬儒主义那样，哦，我不相信任何东西，但几乎就像，哦我的天，我冲破了道德、意识形态和信仰的浅层壳。
It's like I'm seeing behind the Matrix kind of a thing.
就像我在看《黑客帝国》背后的东西。
Yeah, very much. The Matrix was a super popular film in Russia.
是的，非常像。《黑客帝国》在俄罗斯是一部超级受欢迎的电影。
I bet.
我敢说。
Which makes sense, if you think about Russian history, or this generation like Surkov or like Putin. They've lived through communism. They've lived through the mafia state. They've lived through fake democracy, through religious national socialism, or an empire building, which they have now, and it's all the same people. And they've gone through so many different modes of being in the last 30 years, and such blistering progression, that they're kind of left with the feeling that everything is a masquerade.
这是说得通的，如果你想想俄罗斯历史，或者像苏尔科夫或普京这一代。他们经历了共产主义。他们经历了黑帮国家。他们经历了虚假的民主，通过宗教民族社会主义，或他们现在拥有的大国建设，而且全都是同一伙人。在过去30年里，他们经历了这么多不同的存在模式，以及如此灼热的进步，以至于他们有点带着一种感觉，即一切都是一场化装舞会。
So when Surkov says everything is controlled in a construct, what he's actually saying is not a confession. It's a piece of psychological propaganda to say, so there's no point struggling for anything. Don't even try to do any of your silly protest movements. So in a way you're killing-- if you tell people that everything is a conspiracy, it doesn't lead people to revolt. It leads people to go--
所以当苏尔科夫说一切都在结构中受到控制时，他实际上说的不是忏悔。这是一种心理宣传，说的是，所以为任何事情挣扎都没有意义。甚至不要试图做任何你愚蠢的抗议运动。所以从某种程度上说，你正在杀死——如果你告诉人们一切都是阴谋，这不会导致人们反抗。它导致人们——
Give up.
放弃。
--well, then I might as well give up. Yes. But again, we might be over-interpreting here. But it's a book, so we're allowed to.
——嗯，那我也许干脆放弃好了。是的。但再一次，我们可能解释过度了。但这是一本书，所以我们是被允许的。
Like I said before, Surkov is no longer the grand manager of propaganda in Russia. He was sidelined in 2011 after a dispute with Putin. A dis-Putin. But he's still a personal adviser to the president, and he was also an organizer of Russia's takeover of the Crimean Peninsula in Ukraine in 2014. His involvement in that annexation got him sanctioned by the West, meaning he's not allowed to travel to the US or Europe anymore. And he can't have assets in the West, either.
正如我之前所说，苏尔科夫不再是俄罗斯宣传的总经理了。他在2011年与普京发生纠纷后被边缘化了。一个“去普京化”。但他仍然是总统的个人顾问，他也是2014年俄罗斯接管乌克兰克里米亚半岛的组织者之一。他参与那次吞并使他受到了西方的制裁，意味着他不允许再前往美国或欧洲了。他也不能在西方拥有资产。
Surkov was unfazed. "The only things that interest me in the US," he said, "are Tupac Shakur, Allen Ginsberg, and Jackson Pollock. I don't need a visa to access their work," which, you know, good comeback. And he has a point about Allen Ginsberg. God, I love Allen Ginsberg.
苏尔科夫不为所动。“在美国我唯一感兴趣的东西，”他说，“是图帕克·夏库尔、艾伦·金斯伯格和杰克逊·波洛克。我不需要签证来获取他们的作品，”这，你知道，很好的反击。关于艾伦·金斯伯格，他说的有道理。天哪，我爱艾伦·金斯伯格。
"America, you don't really want to go to war. America its them bad Russians. Them Russians them Russians and them Chinamen. And them Russians. The Russia wants to eat us alive. The Russia's power mad. She wants to take our cars from out our garages. Her wants to grab Chicago. Her needs Red Reader's Digest. Her wants our auto plants in Siberia. Him big bureaucracy running our fillingstations. That no good. Ugh--"
“美国，你真的不想打仗。美国，他们是坏俄罗斯人。他们俄罗斯人，他们俄罗斯人，还有那些中国佬。还有那些俄罗斯人。俄罗斯想活吞我们。俄罗斯权力狂。她想从我们的车库里抢走我们的车。她想抢走芝加哥。她需要红色读者文摘。她想要我们在西伯利亚的汽车厂。他庞大的官僚机构经营着我们的加油站。那没好处。呃——”
Sean Cole is one the producers of our show.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人之一。
Act Four, A Matter of Principle.
第四幕，原则问题。
So the anti-government protests last month in Russia were surprising for a few reasons. Their size, the fact that they happened in cities all across the country. These were the first big demonstrations in years in Russia. And there were tons of young people. That was new. Lots of those young people were there because they've been watching these videos online that had been created by the charismatic opposition leader Alexei Navalny, who's the one who called for the protests, which were about government corruption, also the subject of his recent video documentary.
所以上个月俄罗斯的反政府抗议活动在几个方面令人惊讶。它们的规模，它们在全国各地城市发生的事实。这是俄罗斯多年来第一次大规模示威。有大量的年轻人。那是新的。很多那些年轻人之所以在那里，是因为他们一直在网上观看这些视频，这些视频是由具有魅力的反对派领导人阿列克谢·纳瓦尔尼创作的，他是那个呼吁抗议的人，抗议是关于政府腐败的，这也是他最近的视频纪录片的主题。
And then, after the protests were done last month, teenagers started posting their own videos to the internet of their teachers lecturing them about the protests, with kids arguing back.
然后，在上个月抗议结束后，青少年开始将他们自己的视频发布到网上，内容是他们的老师对他们进行关于抗议的说教，孩子们回嘴。
You were called in for a lecture by your principal, you think that very idea of your principal lecturing you on the subject of protest is either unjust or absurd or funny or whatever, and so you film it and post it, just like I think a lot of 16-, 17-year-olds might be tempted to do anywhere.
你被校长叫去听训了，你认为校长就抗议主题对你进行说教的想法要么是不公正的，要么是荒谬的，或者好笑的，随你怎么说，所以你拍下来并发布了，就像我认为很多16、17岁的孩子在任何地方都可能想做的那样。
Joshua Yaffa is a correspondent for The New Yorker magazine in Moscow, and he wrote about one of these videos that was filmed in the provincial town of Bryansk, 200 miles from Moscow. Apparently, there was a student there who tried to enlist other kids to go to the protests, which led to their principal and homeroom teacher to talk to them. Which they filmed.
乔舒亚·亚法是《纽约客》杂志在莫斯科的通讯员，他写了其中一段视频，是在距离莫斯科200英里的布良斯克省的一个小镇上拍摄的。显然，那里有一个学生试图动员其他孩子参加抗议，导致他们的校长和班主任与他们谈话。他们拍了下来。
It's obvious that it was filmed surreptitiously. You see a lot of the desk in front of you and half-cut-off shots of the school principal in front of a chalkboard.
很明显它是秘密拍摄的。你看到很多你面前的课桌和校长在黑板前被切掉了一半的镜头。
OK, and I should say that most of it's just completely black. You see nothing, and you hear sound. And then occasionally the camera bops up.
好的，我应该说大部分时间里它是完全黑的。你什么也看不见，只能听到声音。然后摄像机偶尔蹦出来。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
She's essentially saying, with a tone in her voice that suggests "you naive, juvenile, somewhat immature in the ways of the world" students, are interested in this guy Navalny. What does he really stand for? What is he really offering or suggesting other than just getting rid of the country's leaders?
她基本上是在说，用一种暗示“你们这些天真的、幼稚的、在世事方面有点不成熟的”学生的语气，对这个叫纳瓦尔尼的人感兴趣。他到底代表什么？除了摆脱国家的领导人，他到底提供了什么或暗示了什么？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
The principal says, guys, I can see that you're looking at this problem one-sidedly, and that you lack range in your political view. You see Navalny. You watch his video. And boom, you believe it all.
校长说，孩子们，我看得出来你们是在片面地看待这个问题，你们的政治观点缺乏广度。你们只看到纳瓦尔尼。你们看他的视频。然后轰的一声，你们就全信了。
When you wrote about this recording in The New Yorker, you described her tone as hectoring and frustrated.
当你在《纽约客》写到这段录音时，你形容她的语气是严厉的和沮丧的。
I would say that that's really the most interesting or striking thing about the whole video to me. To me, it sounds like Kira Petrovna, the principal, is experiencing something between confusion, exasperation, anger. I think she's really at a loss. She doesn't understand them, maybe, in the same way that, I don't know, five years ago, seven years ago there was something more shared between her and her students.
我会说那对我来说是整个视频中最有趣或最引人注目的东西。对我来说，听起来像基拉·彼得罗夫娜校长正在经历一种困惑、愤怒和烦躁之间的感觉。我想她真的束手无策了。她不理解他们，也许，就像，我不知道，五年前、七年前，她和学生之间还有某种共同的东西。
At one point, she starts defending Vladimir Putin, saying, you can't blame him for the bad economy. That's because of the sanctions that the European Union and the United States imposed on Russia. And she says, on the world stage and foreign policy, he's doing a great job, which the students challenge.
在一点上，她开始捍卫弗拉基米尔·普京，说，你不能因为经济不好而责怪他。那是由于欧盟和美国对俄罗斯实施的制裁。她说，在世界舞台和外交政策上，他做得很好，学生们对此提出了挑战。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
The student is asking the principal, OK, so what is our foreign policy? America is against us. Europe is against us. And the principal says, OK, well, why is that? What's the reason? And the student, without thinking, says, well, that's because of Crimea. We took it.
学生在问校长，好的，那么我们的外交政策是什么？美国反对我们。欧洲反对我们。校长说，好的，好吧，为什么会这样？原因是什么？学生不假思索地说，好吧，那是因为克里米亚。我们把它拿下了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
And the principal, responding with some surprise or indignation says, so was that bad?
校长回应带着一点惊讶或愤怒说，那是不好的吗？
Because in most of Russia, it's seen as like a patriotic thing to have taken Crimea.
因为在俄罗斯大部分地区，拿下克里米亚被视为是一件爱国的事情。
Yeah. The annexation of Crimea is incredibly popular. It's widely perceived to have been a good thing, basically.
是的。克里米亚的吞并非常受欢迎。基本上被普遍认为是一件好事。
And then the homeroom teacher jumps in and argues with the kids over Crimea.
然后班主任插话，和孩子们就克里米亚争论。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
The teacher says, did we really take Crimea? Didn't they vote and choose to become part of Russia? The kids correctly point out, yes, Russia did take Crimea, and the sanctions were the result.
老师说，是我们真的拿下了克里米亚吗？他们不是投票选择成为俄罗斯的一部分吗？孩子们正确地指出，是的，俄罗斯确实拿下了克里米亚，而制裁就是结果。
Soon the conversation turns to the fighting in eastern Ukraine. Russia officially denies that its soldiers are there, but all kinds of evidence has come out proving that this is untrue.
很快谈话转向了乌克兰东部的战斗。俄罗斯正式否认其士兵在那里，但已经出台了各种证明这是不真实的证据。
And the principal is essentially trying to blame the crisis in Ukraine on America.
校长基本上试图把乌克兰危机归咎于美国。
Let me read exactly what she says because it's so aggressive. She says, kid, you haven't read anything about this and you don't know a thing.
让我读一下她确切说的话，因为它太有攻击性了。她说，孩子，你还没读过任何关于这个的东西，你什么都不知道。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
You've got some very superficial knowledge here.
你这里有一些非常肤浅的知识。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
What started this whole conflict? Maybe it was because America stuck its nose in. And then they start to argue.
这场冲突的起因是什么？也许是因为美国把鼻子伸进来了。然后他们开始争论。
Right. And the student asks, somewhat mockingly of the principal, did you see American troops in Ukraine?
对。学生带着嘲讽的语气问校长，你在乌克兰看到美国军队了吗？
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
And the principal says, did you see Russian troops in Ukraine? And this is this moment where the student reveals this like basic, elementary, non-ideological, factual knowledge, and the student just says, yes.
校长说，你在乌克兰看到俄罗斯军队了吗？这就是那个时刻，学生揭示了这种基本的、基础的、非意识形态的、事实性的知识，学生只是说，是的。
Da.
达（是的）。
There are videos going around. And then comes, really, maybe my favorite line. You have no idea.
到处都有视频流传。然后出现了，我最喜欢的台词。你一无所知。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
And that, to me, gets to the key point of this whole dialogue, which is the kids just have access to this information and just a worldview that they've gotten on the internet themselves-- information that's not on state TV. And that alone seems kind of somewhat destabilizing or uncomfortable for the principal.
对我来说，这抓住了整场对话的关键点，那就是孩子们只是能够接触到这些信息，并且拥有一种他们自己从互联网上获得的世界观——那些国家电视台没有的信息。单单这一点似乎就让校长感到有点不安定或不舒服。
The kids don't watch TV the way older Russians do. The principal tells them, OK, you don't remember how bad it was here before Putin. The country was in chaos. People had to carry guns and knives. And this is when I was in college.
孩子们不像老一辈俄罗斯人那样看电视。校长告诉他们，好的，你们不记得普京之前这里有多糟糕了。国家处于混乱中。人们不得不携带枪支和刀具。那是我在读大学的时候。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
When she says this, and when she parrots talking points that you might hear on Russian state TV, she seems totally sincere. As an American watching this, it's one of the things that's actually most interesting about this video. You think that these government talking points on Crimea or Ukraine or whatever, you wonder if authorities are just mouthing these points and they don't actually believe them. When you hear the principal, she seems totally emotional when she runs through these talking points.
当她说这话时，当她鹦鹉学舌般地重复你在俄罗斯国家电视台可能听到的谈话要点时，她看起来完全是真诚的。作为一个美国人看这段视频，这是这段视频中实际上最有趣的事情之一。你认为这些关于克里米亚或乌克兰什么的政府谈话要点，你想知道当局是否只是在动动嘴皮子说这些点，而他们并不真正相信它们。当你听到校长时，她在说这些谈话要点时看起来完全是情绪化的。
But those talking points are, in a way, emotional, couched in the language of patriotism and appeal to history. Russia as a great power. Russia as this besieged fortress surrounded by enemies who wish it harm. And the students just seem less receptive to those messages.
但这些谈话要点，在某种意义上，是情绪化的，用爱国主义和诉诸历史的语言包裹着。俄罗斯作为大国。俄罗斯作为被渴望伤害它的敌人包围的被围困堡垒。而学生们似乎对这些信息没那么容易接受。
At one point, the kids openly laugh at the country's ruling political party, President Putin's party, United Russia.
在一点上，孩子们公开嘲笑该国的执政党，总统普京的政党，统一俄罗斯党。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
[SNICKERING]
[窃笑声]
We're against United Russia, the kid's saying. The student asks everybody to raise their hands who is against United Russia. And then you get the sense-- this part is dark in the video. You get the sense that lots of hands are going up.
我们反对统一俄罗斯党，孩子说。学生让大家举手，反对统一俄罗斯党的举手。然后你感觉到——视频的这一部分是黑暗的。你感觉到很多手都举起来了。
[SPEAKING RUSSIAN]
[俄语交谈]
[EXCITED MUTTERING]
[兴奋的低语]
This is one of the things that's interesting to me about this because I feel like we read about how the Russian government sort of floods the zone in their own country with all kinds of misinformation and disinformation to make people feel that Putin is doing a great job. And here it seems like you have a bunch of kids who just seem utterly immune to it.
这是关于这件事情让我感兴趣的地方之一，因为我觉得我们读到俄罗斯政府如何用各种错误信息和虚假信息淹没该国的区域，让人们觉得普京做得很好。而在这里，看起来有一群孩子似乎对此完全免疫。
Yeah. And that, I think, must freak out the political advisors and political technologists, as they're called here in Russia, in the Kremlin who just seem to have lost the country's youth. They just don't seem to be able to come up with the kind of messages and rhetoric that, for an older generation, worked so easily and naturally, and it flowed with so little resistance.
是的。而且我认为，那一定吓坏了俄罗斯克里姆林宫里的政治顾问和所谓的政治技术专家，他们似乎已经失去了国家的青年。他们似乎无法提出那种对于老一辈人来说非常容易且自然地奏效，并且几乎没有阻力地流动的消息和修辞。
Joshua Yaffa of The New Yorker magazine, in Moscow.
《纽约客》杂志的乔舒亚·亚法，在莫斯科。
Well, our program was produced today by Jonathan Menjivar. Our staff includes Elise Bergerson, Elna Baker, Zoe Chace, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Karen Duffin, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Miki Meek, Robyn Semien, Alyssa Shipp, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Research help today from Michelle Harris and Benjamin Phelan. Music help from Damien Graef.
好了，我们的节目今天由乔纳森·门吉瓦制作。我们的员工包括爱丽丝·伯格森、埃尔娜·贝克、佐伊·蔡斯、达娜·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、卡伦·达芬、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆、赛斯·林德、米基·米克、罗宾·塞米恩、艾丽莎·希普、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。今天来自米歇尔·哈里斯和本杰明·费兰的研究帮助。来自达米安·格拉夫的音乐帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. Obviously, like so many public figures, people ask him all the time, did he ever meet with Russian officials during the presidential transition?
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《这就是美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交换机构发送给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。显然，像许多公众人物一样，人们总是问他，他在总统过渡期间是否与俄罗斯官员会面过？
Nyet. Nyet. Nyet. Nyet! No!
不。不。不。不！没有！
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《这就是美国生活》的故事回来。